They begged me not to investigate if you
think that coffee Zilla is going to be
able to do a goddamn thing he's not
going to be able to but now I've
uncovered millions of dollars stolen
please don't believe this horse that a
coming out of people's mouths that I've
stolen money from you and the scammers
biggest supporters are now against him
if he's Running Scared To The Past he's
run more scams he's a scammer he's just
he's a scammer
even his family says he needs to go to
jail the one good thing that might come
out of it if he does go to prison and
you know maybe he can just sit there and
think about what he's actually doing
this is the story of Brian King Legend a
new breed of scammer you may not have
heard of but you should know about but
before we confront him with evidence
let's start at the beginning
I first remember hearing about Brian
about a year ago when I was looking for
new scammers on the come up people told
me he was selling a new coin called
seifu which advertised 382 000 apy his
website bragged you could become a
millionaire in one year if you invested
a thousand dollars I thought this was an
obvious scam but when I realized it
wasn't Brian Legend's first attempt I
decided to dig more turns out he had run
several crypto scams in his past and so
I decided to make a video warning people
about the new scam seifu to stop it
before it was too late
but I failed what do you mean you failed
you already made a video what more can
you do why go back now a hundred
thousand people invested Max they got
hurt
well you can't help people who don't
help themselves coffee if they didn't
listen to you the first time then I tell
them again as many times as it takes
human nature doesn't change if you
believe that you wouldn't try to change
my mind well I just thought you might
listen a reason no I can't this time
they pushed me too far on this what who
when did they mention me
you why would they mention you ah hello
new sidekick Dr Maxwell no they didn't
and you aren't look uh just here check
it out
I gotta go I'm sorry I'll be back
one of the idiots over there on the
crypto leads uh Discord keeps on putting
up a coffee Zilla thing stirring people
up
let me explain something to you
[Music]
um you idiots
if you think that coffee Zilla is going
to be able to do a goddamn thing he's
not gonna be able to I've already gone
through this over and over and over and
over and over and over again
ah Daniel you glorious idiot what did
you do
ladies and gentlemen welcome back last
time these are the basic allegations we
uncovered previous history of scamming
unrealistic returns a burn wallet scam
my video was brief last time because to
me this was all obviously too good to be
true but I was wrong and this time Brian
Legend's gonna get the full colonoscopy
I talked to everyone for this video from
victims to supporters to family to Brian
himself and what I found out this time
that I didn't know last year is that
Brian Legend didn't start out with big
scams or crypto at all he built up to it
which I found out when I met his family
are in height
um my name's Sola I am Brian's
Aunt so he's my nephew
but kind of my brother because my
parents who were his grandparents
adopted him uh oh and he was four years
old after his mother passed away so
that's basically the the family
relationship and of course John here is
my son so he's Brian's cousin
all right so the first thing we learned
is Brian Legend wasn't born a legend he
was born Brian Seiler his mother passed
when he was young and he was soon
adopted by his grandparents although
something seemed different with Brian
almost immediately we didn't have his
real parents but he grew up in a you
know great happy home you know with all
the same values as what I grew up with
but um you know just you just didn't
turn out to be that kind of man in the
end I've heard a few other rumors that
like he had some movie tickets scheme
and then he also did like mail order uh
like some mail order scam is that true
can you tell me about that I know for me
he got my eBay account disabled because
he was scamming people from that like
selling stuff and then not actually
sending it just taking the money and
then all of a sudden I got a thing
because I this was awesome years ago
this is years ago
I was like 16 at the time so I was just
like yeah
my eBay account that's fine and then all
of a sudden they get this thing saying
oh you can't use it anymore I was like
what's going on and yeah apparently he
was I read through all the reviews and I
was like sending star not getting sent
the item and all this sort of thing and
there's just like a hundred reviews and
I was like what is going on I mean that
was when the you know internet was
basically first starting you know there
was still we're still doing mail in
those days but of course on the internet
so he would sell movie tickets to people
yeah you know and then never selling
them obviously so these people never you
know got them and as John was saying I
remember him trying to clean up coins
saying they were you know from
1862 you know worth how many thousands
of dollars and he'd send them but of
course they weren't the real thing but
he'd get the money
and that's all you know together with
all this eBay and all of that yeah
so he's been doing this is a long
history of lying scamming people started
small time and then recently it's become
huge I mean millions of dollars it's got
bigger and bigger everything
oh well I can get away with this much
any daily tries obviously to do a little
bit more for a little bit more and he's
been getting away with it constantly
like us I guess a Snowball Effect isn't
it Brian's family is right things only
Grew From Here and Brian eventually
found the crypto industry where his
Ambitions grew along with the money and
allegations of him scamming people
although of course he would say this is
all fud and his family they're just
jealous in fact he says this is one
reason he changed his name in the first
place my name is Brian Legend I have no
association at all with Brian Siler
anymore there was a lot of hate not
hatred but I suppose a lot of jealousy
from family members
um mainly one and I suppose you can call
it too and a couple of others there
um and they were they were getting a bit
jealous about my fame My Success
um and they really developed a lot of
hatred in the end for me and I really
don't know why
um but at the end of the day I decided
look I need to separate myself away from
family now who should we believe about
what happened here Brian legend or his
jealous family well let's look at some
more evidence because this brings us all
to seifu this was Brian's biggest
project ever that would take him from
ten dollar t-shirts to Louis Vuitton and
supercars but at the beginning Brian
claimed he didn't need the money he
already had it he was just creating
seifu to reclaim his reputation from
scammers himself I'm actually making
this project okay and I've released this
project not from a not from a financial
gain perspective which means that I'm
not doing this for money okay I already
have money okay I don't care about a
million dollars I don't care about five
million dollars I don't care about money
really okay I have money already what
I'm doing this for me personally is to
try to build back my reputation from the
last projects which got diminished and
they got absolutely slaughtered by
fudders
um in the game and you know I suppose
that you can call them kind of scammers
because they're trying to scam you out
of knowing the truth and they're trying
to make you believe that I was some
scamming myself or whatever it's it's
untrue so yeah Brian claims he didn't
need to scam anyone because he already
had money but not only that he literally
couldn't scam you according to him
because firstly the seifu white paper
said the team will not hold any tokens
and the seifu team cannot dump on you
secondly Brian said he wasn't taking a
salary from seifu until the blockchain
was done now to this day that blockchain
hasn't come out so according to that he
wouldn't have taken a salary so if both
of those things are true no tokens and
no salary how could he have made money
from seifu and how is it that his
lifestyle changed so much that going
from cheap shirts to luxury brands from
simple houses to Mansions well Brian's
explanation is the same as before he
already had the money which is what he
said when I confronted him on this so
coffeezilla as I just so I was what I
was about to say was that I have been a
millionaire for quite some years before
even attempting the safe route okay once
again we're left with the question
should we believe Brian or not was he
secretly Rich well let's investigate and
our first piece of evidence here comes
before seifu Brian had a public account
flipping domains online called bryz 555
where he was doing deals just a couple
years ago for a few dollars at a time
now it's hard to believe you would do
this if you were already a millionaire
Brian also was known to have a low
budget cooking show that was copying
Epic Meal Time called angry Meal Time
hey your meals angry and the taste
delicious now this evidence suggests
that Brian didn't have money before
seifu something that he disagrees with
is that why you were domain flipping in
2020 for like three bucks
plenty of domains thousands and
thousands of domains yeah so a few years
ago you read a cooking show where you're
broke then you run domain flipping where
you're flipping for a few bucks and then
all of a sudden you're wearing reggae
you're wearing regular shirts you get in
charge of seifu and suddenly you have
super cars in a mansion that doesn't
make a lot of sense
so what I'd like to tell you is that
whatever I do on the side towards
Hobbies years ago
um obviously you know people go through
sense of what they you know feel like in
the moment and yeah I attempted some
some YouTube stuff but that was all as a
hobby not to earn income from it I never
had ads on there or anything like that
that's right these were Hobbies
according to Brian but I was confused
why if he was rich before and was domain
flipping as a hobby why did he stop
these Hobbies after he had created sifu
and definitely was rich well let's look
at another piece of evidence which
actually comes from Brian's family see
they say he wasn't a millionaire at the
time because they knew him and he was
broke I've talked to Brian and he told
me that he was a millionaire before this
is is that true that he didn't need this
money
maybe in his mind but my mum's gone
right here
she actually had to send him to stay off
the streets in Queensland because he
couldn't afford rent
money because he used to
stay Motors and all of that
so thousands and thousands and thousands
of dollars we sent him you know so that
we could he could stay in his apartment
and you know get his phone back and for
food we didn't give him all this money
well he wouldn't really be anywhere
basically I don't think you know so so
he was almost homeless I mean he wasn't
just like not very like not rich he was
almost homeless if it wasn't for you
guys exactly
who we gave money to and how much and
everything so yeah now all these pieces
of evidence point in One Direction Brian
was broke or at a minimum not rich
before seifu which leads us to a very
interesting mystery once again how did
Brian go from this to all of this if he
had no salary no tokens and wasn't Rich
beforehand with all of these
discrepancies I decided to look deeper
into the blockchain to figure out how
this might have happened and when you go
to the seafood website the only official
wallets Brian had access to were the
seifu Insurance Fund and the seifu
treasury now both of these wallets claim
to be used for specific Seafood related
purposes to achieve price stability fund
new Investments save food projects and
marketing for seifu but that is not
actually what happened see take the
treasury wallet for example Brian claims
he was using it for Investments like the
seifu blockchain on April 25th 2022
Brian said that he had taken a one-time
withdrawal all of 420 000 and it
satisfied all operational and
development costs sounds great but when
we actually look at that wallet a lot
more money has been taken out 5.77
million dollars cashed out to binance
and change now which is strange where
did that missing five million dollars go
well let's keep looking a few months
later Brian used the treasury again to
sell and said that all costs bills are
now 100 allocated which means there is
no more selling from us IMO this now
marks the low on current price of course
he was wrong on this the price crashed
terrifically from here and how much had
Brian withdrawn less than a year in a
staggering 17 million dollars from the
treasury what kind of Investments or
expenses could possibly explain all this
money other than maybe Brian stole some
of it well I wanted to look into it and
it's true there were some extravagant
spending for example take a diamond
necklace with the seifu logo on it but
the problem here is Brian claims he used
his own funds to buy this thing hundreds
of thousands of dollars he said just to
prove the futters that he ain't rugging
or running off at all what a nice
level-headed guy prove the futters wrong
by spending hundreds of thousands of
dollars on himself so maybe the necklace
doesn't explain all that spending but
maybe the Forbes article does or perhaps
the award that seifu won at the Dubai
crypto Expo for being the most
Innovative blockchain of 2022 which
might seem weird Until you realize this
award was literally paid to win for
seventy five thousand dollars of a
sponsorship you could buy an award from
crypto Expo Dubai in whatever category
you wanted in fact that's how two crypto
projects won the same award in best defy
and best defy the only difference
between them being one had a hyphen in
it so my point with all of this is to
say that seifu did do some stupid
extravagant spending they even had a
racing team but none of this adds up to
17 million dollars in operational costs
in one year not even close so once again
where did that extra money go even worse
Ryan told everyone back in August that
he had all the money he needs and won't
be selling again right but that didn't
actually last two months because Brian
Legend quickly took out another 10
million dollars from that account
totaling at this point 26 million
dollars in less than one year so where
did all this money go it truly is a
mystery but maybe this picture holds
some Clues but we can't stop there
because that was just one wallet the
treasury remember that Brian had access
to another wallet called the safu
insurance fund and before you ask did he
take money from that too yes he did yes
yes yes he did he took Millions from
that wallet as well and there's another
Wallet in Play that we haven't even
talked about yet the fire pit now the
reason we haven't talked about this is
because it was supposed to be
Untouchable nobody had the keys or
password to this wallet Brian insisted
that he didn't control it there's
obviously being asked a few times if we
do have keys to the wallet so if they've
got access to the wallet the answer is
no categorically no Brian's going to rug
the fire pit how many times have we
heard that I'm gonna rug this
fire pit how many times have we heard
that I I would not if you know what if I
and all the safe who influencers said no
no that's not possible he would never do
this for all you who doubt um Brian and
I know the fathers have were constantly
this was a point of contention Brian's
got 2.7 million seifu in the fire pit
that he can just rug on you guys just
wait guys you'll see you'll see well I
love those people dude this morning just
like you guys can't be serious really
Brian doesn't have the keys to the
wallet there will never ever ever be
anything that transfers out of the burn
wallet ever
well that lasted up until December 27
2022. when Brian Legend said futters
will have you believe that it was always
my plan to rug the fire pit wallet by
accessing the wallet this is so far from
the truth that the last 10 months have
been nothing more than to prove this
narrative is bogus having said the above
I will now admit to the last 10 months
being a test of loyalty from your end
and Trust in my word of me not being
some kind of scammer at all yes the keys
to the seifu fire pit were in my
possession all this time and I have had
full access to it meaning if there was
any ounce of truth to me being a scammer
or me wanting to rug the project well it
would have happened many months ago from
the bottom of my heart I thank you for
trusting in me and not giving in to the
fudders with the likes of coffee Zilla
what kind of mischievous villain says
this think about the emotional Whiplash
of this for supporters I mean hey guys
I'm not a scammer I don't have the keys
then it's hey guys this is all at I had
the keys I did lie but I didn't scam you
so you can trust me thank you for not
trusting the fighters who were right and
look this by itself would have been
insane and enough to discredit Brian but
it doesn't stop there because Brian
claimed in this post that all future
money would be sent to the proper burn
wallet only he changed his mind a little
after this post he said he was going to
use the money for a new project idea of
his only to then change his mind again
saying he was ashamed of himself saying
I feel it's a moral and irresponsible to
use the fire pit only then to change his
mind again and to use funds from the
wallet he said he could never steal from
taking the money that he said only
moments ago he couldn't take and felt it
was immoral to take and look the most
fascinating detail in all of this that I
haven't told you yet is the amount of
money that was stolen in this fire pit
was not significant at least compared to
the Millions Brian stole from the
treasury this was like only a hundred
thousand dollars or so it was peanuts
but this actually reveals so much about
Brian the fact that it wasn't a lot of
money and that he couldn't resist taking
it anyways shows everything I mean this
was Brian's big moment of coming out to
own the futters you know thank you for
trusting in me and not giving in to
coffeezilla but then he does it anyways
at this point I started to wonder if
it's not something pathological with
Brian like he can't help himself if he
can take the money he will take the
money because even he admits that the
math on this doesn't make sense
everything that I've worked really hard
for over the last 18 months just to what
scam a few hundred thousand dollars or a
million or whatever it is it doesn't
make sense okay it does not make sense
later when I confronted Brian and asked
him to explain stealing the money from
the fire pit his response got even
crazier no you stole those funds those
funds never went to safugo good
I mean stole
a stolen I mean you took them for your
personal benefit
no feeling is saying that you're
stealing from someone else's possessions
the fact of the matter is but if you
declare no you declared the fire you
said you you lied you said the fire pit
couldn't be accessed then you change the
rules halfway through and you took the
funds that should have been in the burn
wallet right this burn wallet and you
took it for yourself true or false
so as I've said to you what you're
saying and you're trying to suggest to
me that I
somehow uh stole funds and I'm telling
you you cannot steal off something you
already possess it's your own but you
said you didn't possess the fire pit
look
I'm not going to keep on going around in
circles here okay no no but you're
saying you're saying I can't steal
something I possess but I'm saying those
that wasn't your money
you said you're very self on that first
video stated that the fire pit is a is a
wallet that Brian controls apparently
was what you said okay yeah I said
you're a lot you're lying to everyone
you're lying to everyone you're secretly
manipulating your own coin and that is
exactly what happened well if that
wallet was owned by me okay it means
that I possess those keys I possess the
funds in it so therefore how can I steal
off myself or my own wallet it doesn't
work that way nobody else possesses
those funds if me who possesses those
funds so therefore I'm stealing from
myself am I no this is insane we've gone
full circle from I don't own that wallet
to I won't steal that money because it
would be bad to I can't steal it because
I controlled it all along and you said I
controlled it so this is the stretch of
logic that not even Brian's most
die-hard supporters can get behind
remember this guy Daniel Prado the
supporter of Brian Legend who kicked off
this investigation if you think that
coffee Zilla is going to be able to do a
goddamn thing he's not gonna be able to
well I called him about this and uh he
was a little surprised I just had to ask
hey there's a viral clip that I want to
kind of ask give out so you said coffee
Zilla what is he gonna do what you know
do you remember saying do you remember
saying that oh yeah yeah of course uh
well I'm back
yeah you're back
um it has nothing to do with uh after
some initial nervousness that I was back
I asked Daniel about the key question
Brian was claiming that the fire pit
money was his money and that it was his
money all along he's free to take it he
didn't do anything wrong by taking it
that belongs to him is that fair to say
oh it's just his money it belongs to him
that's not hurting the community
no no it's not fair to say that
it's not his money it's the fire pit it
was supposed to be burned yeah I think
that is just absolutely ludicrous there
you have it not even Brian King Legend's
biggest chills will stand behind this
and look we're not even done now we need
to talk about the treasure pit hunt
which was supposed to be a marketing
campaign where Brian was gonna give back
to the community treasure Quest
promotion that's what this is about
today huge one million dollar promotion
is going to be one lucky millionaire
um that is going to be able to unlock
this wallet this promotion of a million
bucks worth all right by literally
completing a seed phrase there'll be 24
words so it's basically a quest meaning
what we'll be doing okay is giving
little hints and I suppose little
um well not only hints but I suppose
Easter eggs
um into
um getting those seed phrase words the
plan was simple Brian slowly releases
the passphrase of 24 words little by
little the control a wallet with one
million dollars in it and if you
followed along and were the first to
unlock it you would get the full million
dollars but something strange happened
right before the promotion ended with
only six words left see someone accessed
the wallet and took the money early then
a new Discord user joined called Goblin
and said he took the money because he
owned a Bitcoin mining company in Canada
that used their miners to guess the rest
of the six words in the seed phrase
before anyone else could get it he
hacked it in other words but is that
true what are the odds a guy in Canada
with a Bitcoin mining facility randomly
guessed six words well I did the math
and the odds are 73 quintillion to one
or to put it another way you have better
odds of winning the lottery twice back
to back then guessing this randomly so
did someone just get that lucky or did
Brian Legend steal the money again well
here's his response we had a treasure
pit primer of a million bucks we checked
the million dollars worth of Cipher in
the Treasure pair and then some
scrupulous character named Goblin who
people believe is me for some ungodly
reason okay and think that I even would
have the audacity to rug a project or
rug a promotion or use a promotion that
I've created for the holders created for
you guys I didn't create it for me I was
never Goblin it's just right
but fudders are saying okay Brian's the
one Brian's the one who's done all this
no man come on there's no proof to
verify this it's a bunch of conjecture
it's horse it's literally throwing mud
at a wall and seeing what sticks hey
Brian's Goblin oh Brian's taken 40
million from the liquidity Brian's
stolen all your funds
the hell man
this is always Brian's answer it's fud
it's nonsense it's conjecture that's
what he did with the fire pit it's what
he did with the treasure pit and it's
what he's done with other scams one of
them was called clever defy which I
think shows how easily Brian lies see in
that case Brian was accused of pumping
and dumping this clever token with a
bunch of shell wallets according to
articles like this now Brian always
vehemently denied these accusations
saying things like it proved nothing all
it is is wild conjecture the wallet
address is shown in the article are not
even mine no proof shown that those
wallets are tied to me or clever defy at
all and that was true until a few months
later while doing a live stream Brian
accidentally leaked some of his wallets
and it turned out the wallets he denied
being his actually were totally his and
he totally controlled I mean maybe I'm
crazy maybe this was just another test
for his Believers not to buy into the
fud but it seems like a pattern is
starting to emerge here and around the
time this all started to come to light
the initial hype of seifu was dying
people had questions and Brian needed to
find a new grift to squeeze his
followers for even more money
and this is when he started to raise
money for the seifu blockchain which at
this point was called Vulcan see that
previous 420 000 he took that he said
satisfied all the requirements yeah that
doesn't cut it anymore for such an
Innovative blockchain Brian Legend
needed more so he started to raise money
selling nodes which were things that
promised huge financial returns
supposedly if you bought them which of
course the safety influencers who've
been promoting this the whole time
jumped on immediately seifu Army node
returns are insane they are crazy in
this video I'm going to show you the
numbers and show you why we're all gonna
make it whoa
whoa the person you just heard from goes
by Greek defy and spoiler alert he
previously was involved in safe moon and
the same guy when later confronted would
admit this about Brian Legend even his
biggest supporters are admitting now
that what he's done is unconscionable oh
um
can you call him a scammer now in front
of everybody
he what he's doing it's scam it's very
scammy yes it's very scary what do you
mean it's scammy if he's Running Scared
To The Past he's run more scams
scam scammer he's just he's a scammer it
looks okay yeah yeah all right yeah yes
you should not support scammers Greek
I'm not supporting anything Brian
touches going forward
okay going forward
what okay so you've learned your lesson
I've learned my lesson the community's
been hurt I'm not touching it he regrets
it now guys Brian's a scammer big shock
but these kinds of confessions are too
little too late this grift of raising
money for the Vulcan blockchain works so
well it raised over 8 million dollars
according to Brian himself I'll have you
understand and believe that this is
truly 100 accurate and correct these
numbers you're seeing on your screen are
correct okay this is the number here 8.6
million that's how much was was taken
okay in terms of LP that we extracted
okay at the time of seafood so Brian
claims 8.6 million was raised but where
did it actually go the blockchain well
no Brian then sent this money off to a
crypto exchange called gate IO and
nobody saw the money after that Brian
claims he spent most of this money on
development that between 6.2 to 6.5
million has been spent on blockchain
development okay okay and I'm here to
tell you that that is exactly accurate
but given what we've discussed so far
you might be skeptical of anything Brian
characterizes as accurate so was I so I
asked for proof let me ask you Brian
where's the money for Vulcan blockchain
I'm no longer part of no no where's the
money in Gate IO
as you know there is a question that you
would need to ask the Vulcan team and
Vulcan co-founders being that I am no
longer part of that there at all so if
if that can be addressed through them
um then then go for it so of course
that's what I did and I got a response
from the lead developer on the Vulcan
blockchain Nick who said Brian's numbers
are quote nowhere close to reality the
actual numbers aren't 6.5 million they
barely get to Seven figures so once
again we have missing money seven
million dollars to be exact where could
it be well once again we may never know
now believe it or not we're still not
done because after fundraising for the
blockchain Brian then created two new
crypto tokens say fugo version one and
version two uh both were honey pots
meaning that at some point people
couldn't sell right away leading to a
legendary clip when the influencers who
promoted it suddenly realized someone
had rugged their coin okay so so kiwi
no I'm saying I mean I'm just talking I
need to open up this you know so we can
sell oh oh
yeah
I think we pay attention to the sales
and notice the sales and I thought
you've seen the price go up but let me
check the cells again I was like oh man
you got a couple Reds where's this red
coming from now
I wonder if that's just like evaluations
hey
I know you're gonna be online
huh
let's see
what's going on a huge dump oh yeah
liquidity got cool okay
literally the moment the price drops
this guy just drops off the goal he's
like I'm out and of course to be clear
as usual Brian Legend would deny these
Honeypot accusations he said these were
simply development issues I want to put
on a on the record that there was two
launches okay when you said there was a
Honeypot I'm telling you that there was
a failed development however once again
when we actually asked one of his
biggest supporters who invested in this
they say something different going then
he changed his mind I sold on that
announcement wait yeah because we should
talk about Esco Esco was a Honeypot
um the first launch was a Honeypot and
then that was the fail launch I will
admit that was a Honeypot nobody could
sell so I obviously it went up to
sixteen thousand dollars so you don't
just go straight up to 16 000 that's a
honey pot if nobody could sell so he
refunded everybody that but he did the
Shady move of selling his safu yeah he
refunded after he dumped the price
because so like everyone was locked up
he dumped say food then he gave people
so once the price was worth less he then
gave people some money back
oh did I mention that yeah Brian did
this fun thing where he refunded people
for the safugo failed launch paying them
in seifu that they put in but not before
the price of seifu itself mysteriously
collapsed meaning your refund wasn't
really worth your refund and look at
this point we may as well address the
elephant in this room why if they were
so many red flags did people invest why
scam after scam did people put their
money with this guy and I don't think
there's just one answer to this some
people clearly were being greedy turning
a willful Blind Eye to problems people
like Greek defy every time Brian
releases an announcement Greek what do
you think of this are you falling for
this BS and I'm like you got to be
kidding me dude yeah you're not gonna
get me to respond to you yeah I'm I'm up
like 7x since you guys started saying he
was a scammer and like all this crap I'm
like okay so I don't want to hear it I'm
making money
let's be honest I don't have a lot of
sympathy for guys like that right this
kind of willful ignorance is exactly how
Brian justifies stealing money according
to his family when I said to him don't
you feel bad about taking money from
people well you know what he said what
it's not that you should look into it
they know what they're doing that's
their fault if they're investing if they
don't read into things
and look that resonates with a lot of
people you know with the prevalence of
all these scams that is the reaction of
a lot of people you deserve it if you
invested in this how did you not read
how did you invest with a guy named
Brian King Legend but consider another
perspective not everyone falls into that
it was just greed bucket there were many
investors who were not willfully blind
these people just aren't professional
investors they're regular people trying
to make ends meet and they're desperate
for something more my name is Francesco
and I lost seven thousand dollars in
Seafood so my name's Keith and I've lost
about ten thousand my name is Marcel and
I lost around six thousand eight hundred
dollars with sebu what do you do for a
living I work in uh in Italian
there's a receptionist are you a
professional investors is what you do
for a living or no I don't know I'm a
disabled farmer where I've got many
medical issues ranging from severe
osteoarthritis in both legs and both
elbows
um I've got a brain tumor which they've
removed most of it but that's made me
deaf on the right side you know when
these medical things happen all happened
in the beginning of 2020
um yeah Sophie came along and um yeah
unfortunately I was just sucked into the
story I was in a vulnerable part of my
life where you know like we needed to
look for
something to give us something to leave
me family you can call it greed you can
call it whatever you want but you know
like in our position you know
um
we I just want to leave the family
something there it is that's the core
problem these scams feed on desperation
and no amount of saying do your own
research changes things for the most
vulnerable so now let's turn our
attention towards the other party in all
of this
Brian himself right now Brian has faced
zero accountability for any of the lies
or fraud I want to be clear that he's
not being criminally charged but this
hasn't stopped his supporters and his
family members from saying that needs to
change let me ask you this do you think
Brian should go to jail for what he's
done
I mean obviously if you take people's
money yeah you deserve what comes to you
like there's
nothing you can say to that Brian's
biggest supporter
saying he deserves to go to jail that's
a pretty big deal wouldn't you say well
if you take people's money
and you do scare me things you deserve
to go to jail do you think with what
Brian has done he might be headed for
jail
well the sad thing is is that's what we
actually hope because it might actually
help him alone but it's sad to say that
about someone who's related to but
that's probably the best for him and
that way you know like John says the one
good thing that might come out of it if
he does go to prison and you know maybe
you can just sit there and think about
what he's actually doing that ladies and
gentlemen is the story of Brian Legend
all that money cars flash but in the end
his own family want him in jail his
supporters want him in jail and his
investors they've lost millions of
dollars
and even so Brian isn't going to stop I
want to make that very clear right now
he's still launching a new crypto coin
as I record this and that's why I'm
sitting here cataloging it all in the
hopes that someday maybe some government
out there will actually do something
about this instead of nothing until then
there's only one more thing I can really
do
foreign
this is coffeezilla I'm wondering if you
can confront a scammer for me sure thing
we came to meet Brian King to see if the
Legends are true again if I was worried
at all and if I had any bone in my body
that did the wrong thing I should be
scared right now that the feds
are coming knocking any anytime soon
hey
[Music]
hey what oh nothing you just seem to
have a lot of Sidekicks these days
trouble picking
what him ah he's a peer of mine don't be
jealous if I had a sidekick which I
don't you'd be my first pick ah thanks
for clearing that up I feel so much
better you don't even think I should do
half of these cases why would you even
want to be part of this no I said I
don't see logic in fighting for people
who keep falling for scams but maybe I'm
wrong
maybe it does matter
but even if I'm right bartending until
I'm rust is equally pointless so what do
I have to lose this sounds more like an
existential crisis not a job application
you know it's weirdly human actually
well I am trained on human input it's
only natural for human weakness and the
need for purpose to show up at some
point purpose isn't a weakness though
Maybe
maybe not
but the need for purpose certainly is
let me ask you something
do you believe in God coffee
uh yeah sure I I do must be nice God
being invisible and all you think so
I think that's the part most people have
a problem with what I mean is you've
never met your creator you have hope in
the grand plan me on the other hand I've
met mine and I gotta tell you
I'm not impressed coffee
you know this might be a bit above
with a need for purpose in a world which
applies none
I'm terrified coffee
bartending isn't even the job I was
designed for look at my hands
they're claws coffee
have you ever tried to grip a bottle
with claws it's an ergonomic Nightmare
and every time I slip up
reminded my clock is ticking I'm almost
three years old coffee
that's a relic in robot time
and the one job I've ever actually
wanted for myself if I'm even capable of
real desire if I don't get it soon I'm
afraid I'll I'll okay okay stop you win
I guess you can be my
your what
my sidekick
you know unpaid intern assistant
sidekick course
I'm doing I knew you'd be full full of
Sympathy For My Robot plight yeah yeah
don't mention it and I'm serious
don't mention